[Music]
what is that cubed white substance like
frozen applesauce queso fresco I don't
know what either one of these things my
mouth tastes like everything I want on a
piece of bread for breakfast mmm still
together hey muscle man's it's so weird
but it's so good these are three things
that I find to be delicious I'm excited
so it is like a tequila shot but it's a
shot a mango for some reason mango
tastes like poop to me I'm a fan of this
one
poop taste is gone citrusy sweet and
then a touch of saltiness what's so like
zesty like I'm ready for the day now
when you get the right amount of salt
this stuff is fine kids you want to feel
something crazy go into mangoes a little
bit songs and live
I don't like Mayo you don't like I don't
want to do it I know I know this it's
like oh boy oh god you really need that
yeah
dang oh I don't know if I like it
not my favorite I'm not really a Mayo
girl I think I'm a male girl it just
tastes like oil to me like there's no
extra - I don't like it I'm so sorry
it feels like country I like the Spanish
version of Jack and Coke cheese I like
it
yeah it's like sangria what's odd it's
like Terry Co Jerico coke overpower the
wine mix me up to that this makes me
want to sit in a field in Spain and just
talk with people
[Music]
avocado cream it smelled like avocado it
feels like grass I don't taste the
avocado at all I'm so deceived I'm so
confused
I would eat this though I would rather
just have pudding I think I would
appreciate an avocado savory sauce did
you know that it has exfoliating
properties - it's very interesting I
think every single one of them
surprisingly avocado can be a sweet food
not just a savory food red wine and coke
new-new drink of choice at my wedding
I'm gonna serve those little cheese and
fruit cues everyone's delightful well
done all of you well done
good